Es knallt sehr laut die erde bebt ein riesiger leuchtender feuerwehr erhält den himmel über dem mittleren westen der usa
Und teilen kanadas die menschen verfallen in panik handelt es sich um eine alien invasion oder ist das jetzt der untergang der erde
Ihr habt euch dieses thema war whatsapp gewünscht und ich beantworte alle fragen dazu denn solche ereignisse sind tatsächlich
eine reale bedrohung jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Es war der reinste horror für diejenigen die diesen abend über den südlichen michigan
miterlebt haben auf twitter hieß es für mich war klar dass ich da entweder eine invasion von außerirdischen oder die
apokalypse beobachtet eine frau schrieb wir waren uns sicher dass gerade jemand unser haus angreift
Die sozialen netzwerke quellen über mit meldungen fotos und videos der helle feuerball erleuchtet
Gegen 20 uhr abends am 16 januar für wenige sekunden den himmel über michigan ohio und ontario
alles wirklich dicht besiedelte regionen der wetterdienst aus ohio gab dann aber
entwarnung der knall oder fernlicht seien nicht von einem gewitter ausgegangen aber von was all das wurde stattdessen verursacht von einem
mitglied der zum einen für den riesigen feuerball am himmel sorgte nicht ganz geklärt ist offensichtlich ob man das objekt wohl korrekter
Weise als metroid oder bereits als kleinen astro ihn bezeichnen kann einfach gesagt sind mit der diesen kleiner als erst zu ihnen beim
eindringen in die atmosphäre
können sie für sternschnuppen oder in sehr hellen feuerkugeln
verursachen wenn sie nicht komplett verglühen wird ein meteorit zum
Meteorit mit tee am ende die nasa sprich in einer offiziellen mitteilung aber von einem kleinen asteroiden
Basierend auf den neuesten daten wurde der extrem
Helle licht streifen, am himmel von einem 6 fuß breiten weltraummission einen kleinen asteroiden verursacht
er dann mit einer geschätzten geschwindigkeit von
36.000 meilen pro stunde in die erdatmosphäre
Irgendwo, im südosten von michigan ein und explodierte mit etwa zehn tonnen gmt am himmel
Also, er war ungefähr zwei meter
groß und knapp
60.000 kilometer pro stunde schnell wahnsinn also
Aber eigentlich ganz harmlos jedenfalls für einen asteroiden wenn er nicht der vorbote für etwas größeres wäre weil
Er
So rasend schnell unterwegs war erschütterte die explosion
sogar den boden in der region die behörden hatten ein seismisches ereignis mit der stärke 2 registrieren dazu der
Erdbebenforscher der eu von der universität michigan das war eindeutig eine explosion in der atmosphäre und kein erdbeben das
seismogramm
zeigt deutlich die unterschiede zu kleineren regionalen erst sehen
es könnte also zu einem anschlag gekommen sein einige zeit nach der horror nach
Verkündete ein suchtrupp stücke gefunden zu haben und zwar in einem see in michigan
Dass die erde von meteoriten getroffen wird ist kein seltenes ereignis experten sind sich einig um solch ein
Sicht- und hörbare spektakel wir haben 16 januar zu verursachen muss es sich
Um objekte handeln die mindestens einen durchmesser von einem meter haben
Dies passiert dem forschungsteam aus michigan zufolge alle paar monate laut nasa fängt die erde täglich rund
18 tonnen
Ja, weltraum material ab zum großteil winzige teilchen deren durchmesser nicht mal einen millimeter beträgt für die nasa selbst ist ein
solches ereignis von mitte januar kaum der rede wert denn die explosion von tscheljabinsk von 2013 sprach rund
58.000 tonnen dmt und sorgte für knapp
1500 verletzte und gesperrte fenster in sechs städten auch hausdächer
Und autos wurden beschädigt laut nasa wurden allerdings noch nie menschen von einem
meteoriten getötete glücklicherweise wurde das ganze phänomen mitte januar von vielen verschiedenen kameras und sensoren
von verschiedenen standorten aus
aufgezeichnet dadurch versprechen sich die forschungsteams mehr informationen zu der größe und der flugbahn des objekts zu
bekommen das planetary die fans koordination office der nasa
Hat das hat es vor allem auf große asteroiden abgesehen kleinere objekte werden da er schnell
Übersehen und sind auch nicht so interessant und diese einheit hatte die usa ihr letztes jahr eingerichtet
Um erdnahe asteroiden zu entdecken und zu verfolgen denn die können uns ziemlich gefährlich werden ja und die größeren sogar gelten
als auslöser von massensterben auf der erde alle paar millionen jahre
Steuert ein großer asteroid auf die erde zu der das leben tatsächlich bedroht die nasa hat deswegen das ziel bis
2020 alle erdnahen asteroiden die größer als
140 meter sind zu entdecken denn genau diese könnten der erde gefährlich werden und es gibt wahnsinnig viele
unentdeckte das zu ihnen die gefahr ist also groß von einem solch riesigen
Himmelskörper getroffen zu werden und auch nur sehr schwer einzuschätzen da die asteroiden
auch ihre flugbahn öfter ändern das geschieht auch ganz ohne den vorbeiflug an größeren planeten zum beispiel durch die einstellung von
anderen kleineren asteroiden immer mehr
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler warnen jetzt vor dem hohen risiko eines größeren ein start auf der erde wie oft das in den ersten
13 jahren dieses jahrhunderts passiert ist wurde ja vor einiger zeit bekannt
26 asteroiden sind auf der erde eingeschlagen darauf gekommen sind findige wissenschaftler in sie hatten die idee beim weltweiten atomteststopp
Überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob es andere größere explosionen auf der erde gab und es waren 26 und es konnten nur asteroiden einsteige sein nichts anderes
Hat eine solche braucht lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei vorher gesehen nur einer alle anderen kamen
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes aus heiterem himmel jedes jahr schlagen also zwei
größere asteroiden hier auf der erde ein
wie sehr hatten wir großes glück denn die gesteinsbrocken schlugen mehr in wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten gebieten ein und
verdampften bereits in der atmosphäre
Wie hoch ist also das risiko wirklich wie schnell ein asteroid oder komet
auf einem planeten einschlagen kann das wurde 1994 deutlich der komet shoemaker
Levy ist ein beeindruckendes beispiel entdeckt wurde haben 24
693 am 16 juli 1994 also nur gut ein jahr später
Schlugen die ersten bruchstücke auf dem jupiter ein sie hatten eine sprengkraft achtung von
50 millionen die roscheba bomben der jupiter hat allerdings ein deutlich größeres und stärkeres
Kavitation ausfällt als die aber trotzdem ist das risiko auch hier hoch millionen und abermillionen
gesteinsbrocken rasen durch unser sonnensystem und dabei sind die zahlen allein zu unserem planeten
Beeindruckend es wird vermutet dass etwa eine million asteoriden sich im bereich der erdumlaufbahn
befinden davon kennen wir inzwischen immer mehr nach aktuellem stand sind
1599 objekte die wir kennen die in unserem sonnensystem umher
Schritt das ist schon deutlich mehr als noch vor ein paar jahren aber tatsächlich sind es wohl millionen die in unserem sonnensystem
Umher greifen wir kennen also nur einen kleinen teil und deswegen schlagen forschungsteams seit jahren immer wieder erlauben sie plädieren für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines koordinierten
frühwarnsystems und wirklich effektive zur abwehrstrategien sind noch immer nicht ausgetüftelt die nasa arbeitet
zusammen mit hochdruck daran potenziell gefährliche asteroiden abzulenken beispielsweise mit laser oder raketen
allerdings müssen wir fürchten dass einer der statistisch gesehen zwei asteroiden
Jedes jahre einschlagen in einer gegen auftritt in der millionen menschen eben das will eine
private initiative jetzt verhindern ehemalige astronauten um den space shuttle piloten
wollen asteroiden finden die zumindest städte länder und kontinente zerstören könnt und damit sie
Im frühzeitig erkannt werden wollte ihre organisationen bees
612 einen privat finanzierten satelliten in den weltraum schicken der der zu ihnen mit einer wärmebildkamera findet doch die
initiative bekam das geld nicht zusammen die nasa kündigte den vertrag zum start des satelliten das
Sieht dann so schlecht aus jetzt will die organisation kleinere und billigere satelliten ins weltall schicken um nicht mehr
So hohe finanzielle hürden zu haben und raketenstarts die werden ja auch immer billiger dankt allen masc
Also es könnte vielleicht bald realität werden dieses frühwarnsystem auf jeden fall
Müssen wir handeln denn das was in michigan passiert es wird ganz schnell
eine große
Katastrophe nämlich dann wenn der assault nur etwas größer ist und in einem besiedelten gebiet einschlägt ja wenn er als erstes neues zu asteroiden
einsteigen und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen an
vom neuesten video eben vorab von mir garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt
Mit mir in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge machen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau glocke vergessen dafür
Unten abonnieren hier überall ja und jetzt geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken sos schreibt an der erde vorbei beginn einer neuen ära ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran